uh
welcome everyone this is 1413 psychology
and economics also known as behavioral
economics
my name is frank schilbach i'm a faculty
member in the economics department
teaching and doing research in
behavioral economics and
psychology and economics and development
economics
there's syllabi over here in case
anybody uh uh needs one
so let me sort of start with introducing
ourselves uh including myself
as i said i'm uh frank schilbach i'm an
economics
phd i'm from harvard recently um i'm
from
germany in case uh as you may have
noticed i do research at the
intersection of development behavioral
economics in particular i'm interested
in
integrating uh psychological issues and
uh helping us understand better
um uh the lives of the poor and so they
study all sorts of issues related to
poverty
how poverty itself affects people's
behavior um
and how conditions of poverty or things
that are associated with poverty might
feed back into people's decision making
and their productivity or labor market
behaviors
and then perhaps sort of lead to the
persistence of poverty through those
kinds of effects
so i have some work on financial
constraints how financial constraints
affect people's behavior
in terms of thinking about money itself
i have some work on sleep deprivation
among the urban poor
i'm thinking about pain and substance
abuse and how that might affect people's
choices
uh uh most recently i'm interested in
uh things related to mental health in
particular depression and loneliness
how those might affect people's
well-being and then their um behaviors
um i have um office hours um
where you can sign up on my website uh
currently they're on tuesday afternoons
but you know if you cannot find
times that work for you please email me
and you'll find some time that that
works out
my assistant is krista moody in case you
want to sort of get a hold of me and and
i
um i'm not available for some reason you
can reach out to her
um so now let me give you sort of the
overview of the class
i'm going to start sort of uh reading
through four things one first i'm going
to sort of tell you what is this class
what is behavioral economics or what is
psychology economics what do we mean by
that is it sort of just putting two
fields together
or is it something more specific which
you'll argue uh it is
i'm going to give you some example then
about like um uh
how you might sort of use behavioral
economics um in a specific example
uh and a policy that might affect all of
you and in fact it will because we have
a specific laptop policy in this class
uh and we'll tell you a little bit how
to think about this there will also be a
problem set
that will help you think about this a
bit more uh then we talk about somewhat
boring uh course logistics
um and at the end we do a questionnaire
quiz um for everybody
in part because we want to know some
information for you in part we want to
sort of learn a little bit about
some decisions that um you might make
okay
great sorry this is
okay so what is um psychology economics
so you may have heard of this uh the
class used to be called economics and
psychology
or behavioral economics uh for our
purposes that's kind of like all um
um uh the same some economists sort of
argue that um
uh all economics is about behavior so
like you know uh behavioral economics is
sort of a bit of a weird word
um so that's why partially i'm using
sort of the word psychology and
economics
in some sense it's sort of broader than
that one definition is it's a field
of economic academic research that
studies the joint influences of
psychological and economic factors
on behaviors you could be sort of
broader and say we're trying to
integrate insights from not just
psychology but also anthropology
sociology medicine
psychiatry etc and so on into economics
and trying with an attempt to make
economic models
more realistic and therefore more
predictive and help us understand
people's behavior better
and then help us uh make better policies
perhaps
in trying to influence um people's
behavior
now uh as i said you know that's
medicine sociology etc
broadly be trying to use insight from
those fields and trying to understand
have you missed something by
making the fairly stark assumptions that
economic models um usually
make that leads me to what are the
standard economics
models in some sense what we're going to
try and study to some degree is
deviations from the classical or the
the sort of the standard economic model
so then of course we need to understand
what is the standard economic models to
start with
which leads me to in part uh some
prerequisites of the class or you should
have taken at least some economics or
know
some economics to start with because i'm
going to talk a lot about sort of
deviations from those models and sort of
if you haven't sort of taken any uh
class before don't really
know that very well then understanding
the deviations will be a little bit
tricky so for those of you who have
taken economic classes what do we
usually assume about people's behavior
what are sort of some of the assumptions
that we make
about economic behavior
yes
stable preferences yes um so first well
defined preferences in the sense of like
people know what their preferences are
they can state them
and then they're also stable in a sense
of like when i ask you today
would you rather have apples or bananas
um uh that'll
not change unless they're sort of new
information or your circumstances change
of course if i ask you tomorrow and you
already have a bunch of apples and then
you'd say you want bananas
that doesn't mean your preferences have
changed but if i ask you about
tomorrow what would you like for lunch
you tell me a choice you want apples
rather than bananas
and then tomorrow you show up and
nothing else has changed and you say now
i want bananas well then your
preferences are not
stable that's one assumption yes what
else do you have yeah
more broadly they're rational yes and
what does that mean
they behave deterministically to
optimize some utility function
right exactly so people essentially
optimize some utility functions so we
say here people
have a utility function they know what
that is and you're sort of saying that
maximize it to to optimize in a certain
way they don't make mistakes in that
maximization
process so that's to say if you tell me
you like apples
over bananas uh and then you choose
bananas well then you know something is
sort of going wrong in some ways that we
haven't fully understood it might be
that you're sort of like just making
uh mistakes that could be construed as
uh irrational it's hard to rationalize
with a model
what else
self-interest yes so like usually in a
lot of models um
all like the sort of the the easiest
models are very narrowly defined
self-interest so people care about
themselves they care about what they
consume and not about what others
consume or
or or what others think of them sort of
narrowly defined
self-interest yes
yes so essentially perfect self-control
usually a sort of
one version of putting that one version
of putting that is in some sense sort of
going back to what you're saying earlier
sort of to say stable preferences
if i'm telling you i'd like to exercise
tomorrow and that's my preference
uh tomorrow i'm not gonna sort of be
like oh yeah actually you know i changed
my mind and now i'm just watching movies
or the like
right so that's the version of sort of
preferences being stable but
the inherent underlying issue there is
like self-control problems in the sense
of like
if i like certain things or make certain
plans for the future
i have the self-control to follow
through on those plans that's usually an
assumption and that
then shows up as preferences being
stable
what else yeah
yeah so usually there is like a discount
um factor in terms of like how much you
uh like consumption today versus
consumption tomorrow
um that is usually in any economic model
usually we think of like the discount
factor being
constant as like how you think about
today versus tomorrow is the same
as you think about today versus in two
days from now or in like a year from now
and a year and a day from now so usually
there's a constant discount factor for
the future usually
we sort of employ economic sorry
constant discounting or exponential
discounting
what else do we have yeah risk reverse
yes risk aversion in the sense of like
yes people um
are risk-averse and people often sort of
define their preferences over
outcome so we have a utility function
that we tend to concave and the utility
function
is and we'll get to this in a few
lectures but the utility function tends
is concave and it's defined over outcome
as opposed to over
changes of outcomes that shows up
usually as sort of like essentially like
a
a strictly concave utility function and
that's
risk aversion what about information how
do people
think about information how do they use
information
bayesian and what what does that mean
exactly so people essentially are
perfect uh information
processors you can call them bayesians
but essentially it's sort of for those
of you know that it's sort of the use
bayes rule essentially
which is to say uh if you gave a
statistician a problem how to update
information
people are able to do that in their
heads and you know that's a pretty stark
assumption but essentially it's like
when you people have certain information
uh standard economics does not
necessarily assume that everybody has
full information in a sense that
everybody knows everything
but if you give them some information
then they update
their uh beliefs accordingly right so
they essentially they optimally use new
information and then form their beliefs
their posterior beliefs based on having
a new information and what they believed
previously um their priors there's
another assumption usually and i sort of
can actually
sort of put this out for you which is
there's another assumption that is
people have no taste for beliefs or
information
what do we mean by that we mean by that
as essentially people use
information only to make decisions so if
you tell me something about like what's
going to happen tomorrow or if you tell
me something about
my health status or the like i use that
to make better decisions so if you tell
me i'm sick
i'm going to use that information to go
to the doctor
but people usually don't assume that
people have certain beliefs about
whether they're sick or healthy or
whether they're smart or not or are they
good looking or not
usually the assumption is that beliefs
are only used so information is only
used to make better decisions
not that people get utility from beliefs
but instead you might say well i'm
really good looking and smart
and maybe smarter than you actually are
and the reason why people might believe
that is because that makes them feel
good about themselves
that's what they're usually an
assumption that
people standard economic models make
i think we mentioned almost everything
we sort of said bayesian information
processor essentially
processing information optimally
well-defined and stable preferences
maximize expected utility which is sort
of like in some sense um
rationality if you want apply
exponential discount weighting
a current and future well-being people
are narrowly
defined in terms of their self-interest
and people have preferences over final
outcomes not changes
so what you care about is how the
weather is today not kind of like how
the weather changed between yesterday um
and today or tomorrow and we'll talk
about all of these
by the way these are all sort of like
some terms that seem maybe
unfamiliar to you we'll talk about all
of these kinds of assumptions and
perhaps how to deviate from them
specifically okay so now now that we
have those
assumptions now what kinds of deviations
uh when you look into the world and sort
of
one part how you think about behavioral
economics is uh in some sense think
about the world and try to sort of
observe what's going on in the world
and try to see which assumptions might
be violated um
in an important way and try to sort of
improve our models
so when you think about the world and
look at these assumptions can you come
up with real world examples
um uh that might sort of violate these
assumptions
yes um the uh the last assumption
that you listed uh the one
beliefs or information is violated on a
constant basis people
tend to believe what they want to
believe and you have an example specific
um this is very common as regards like
political matters i'm not gonna name
like
obvious reasons but uh like people
like often like choose to discount
information
that goes against their belief right um
right so
um so one reason could be and there's uh
quite a bit of work recently we'll talk
a little bit about this in this class
about sort of
how political beliefs or other reasons
why people might be
motivated to believe certain things one
clear example would be sort of climate
change
not just because of political reason
there's some interesting work about like
when people live in flood areas for
example what do they think about climate
change
and sort of you might sort of say well
if you really uh live in an area that's
potentially
affected by floods you might really want
to know about climate change and know
what's going on and really try to inform
yourself
but what people tend to do is sort of
try to ignore the issue and try to sort
of be happy
as long as sort of uh nothing happens
now that's one example yes
yes um so purposes might not be well
defined
so say like if i have a decision on what
i want to eat
i want to eat like steak over chicken if
i'm presented with the opportunity
but i prefer chicken or pork
but i might also prefer poor purple
steak right so it's not always
well defined right so one part that
you're telling is like essentially so
one one part might be it's might not
just be well-defined
there's other issues like for example
that irrelevant other autism assumption
economics usually is to say if you
choose between a and b
the availability of seed should not
matter for your choice between a
and b but often that's not the case
right so if i offer you apples and
bananas and you also can get cherries
now suddenly your choice between apples
and bananas might change
even if you can't get the cherries like
if i even if you don't choose the
cherries um
eventually so exactly so like there
might be sort of people's preferences
might not be
uh well defined they might also not be
stable
any other example yes um also for the
well-defined preferences like we have
information processing constraints if
i'm given a menu
of 100 choices it's going to be
difficult for me to
know which one right exactly so the
the people have lots of information
around themselves and like if you think
about like
to process that information if you go to
a supermarket it's impossible to know
uh all the prices all the goods and make
all these choices so in some sense we're
like there's an abundance of
information everywhere and you know we
have to sort of figure out how to how to
deal with
with that any other example yes
right exactly so one part is to say
people
um have preferences of a final outcome
not changes which would just say
uh you know you might feel about the
weather in certain ways
uh um you know depending on like how the
weather was yesterday
another version of that would be like
you evaluate your
the outcomes that you get based on your
expectations and sort of if you thought
you know today is going to be really
nice
uh or you know today is something that
your day is going to be really good but
then it happened to be not as good for
whatever reason the weather is bad
or you know something bad happened to
you today the typical assumption would
be to say well
um you should just evaluate the final
outcome it shouldn't matter what you
thought about previously would what
might happen
you're going to look at like what
happens at the end and that's how you
evaluate your
uh your well-being
yes um you might need a commitment
device
so that you don't uh like you might
avoid buying
potato chips because you think you'll
eat them that doesn't really make sense
right so people might on purpose
restrict their choices in certain ways
right so you might sort of um and this
is what gets me eventually to the
laptop policy but people might sort of
essentially know that in the future they
make certain choices
you might um for example
in the laptop case you might say i'm
gonna use a laptop in class
with all the best intentions to taking
notes and uh paying attention
but you know at the end of the day you
know you're gonna like watch the
football review from yesterday or
whatever other stuff comes up you're
going to chat with your friends and so
on and so forth
so now in some sense if you're
sophisticated as in like if you know
um what you're going to do in case you
sort of make certain choices
you might say i choose not to even allow
myself to use a laptop
at all the reason being because i know
that essentially
i'm going to misbehave in the future and
that's sort of we'll talk about this um
soon i think in lecture three or four
which is essentially people's demand for
commitment as we call it which is to say
people have demand for restricting their
choice
and in any neoclassical model does this
make any sense because like you're going
to choose optimally anyway and then you
need to make
the best choice for yourself in any case
that's an assumption so why would you
ever sort of shut down certain choices
because for example in an emergency or
there might be something really
important coming up in class
where you might want to use your laptop
regardless of what's happening uh why
would you shut that
uh down exactly so demand for commitment
is is is another example
uh yes people are also not
like anywhere near perfect uh invasion
information processors either
we are as a general rule
people are pretty bad at uh
updating their um you know
their their beliefs based on new
information and we frequently traffic
in 100 and zero percent certainties
like very often which um you know
far more often than like what you would
um expect from
an invasion information right
exactly so you know uh one summary of
that is to say bayes rule a lot of this
sort of updating uh behavior is really
hard
it's actually tough to do um and for
those of you who do statistics math etc
you might be able to do that very well
but in way you're like a very small
share of the population
who actually uh uh does that well
but even among those you know there's a
bunch of
stuff that's really hard to compute in
your head uh you might be able to write
it down and figure it out eventually
but usually the assumption is that
people just do all of this stuff in
their heads and really complicated
problems
and you know that's that's sort of
clearly not the case in many situations
and then of course like um uh that's
sort of
one part of that sort of among mit
students uh but then you know
um there's other populations that are um
uh less educated they might not even
know what bayes rule is
uh uh they might be illiterate and so on
and so forth so is there the assumption
of like
people's perfectly processing
information is even perhaps more
um um uh you know 10 years
right so there's two parts to that
there's essentially people
uh this is essentially the assumption of
narrowly defined self-interest people
caring only about themselves of their
own consumption
so there's two parts to that one is you
might care about your friends you might
give money to your friends you might
sort of help them out you might help
them with homework you might help them
in
uh you know any other situations you
might send money to charity and so on
and so forth this is kind of like
you care about other people like the
well-being of other people is in your
utility function one way or the other
the second part is what you uh uh
already uh
discuss as well which is kind of like
social influences call it which is
essentially
peer effects you care a lot about what
other people think about you
you care a lot about what other people
do people get jealous
people get angry people get envious and
sort of their behavior about what they
want
at the end of the day is very um
volatile or malleable essentially based
on uh influences from others
right and that might sort of show up uh
in all sorts of ways
including in terms of like peer effects
um people do all sorts of things because
other people think
that's cool but it's not necessarily
what's best for
them if they had to choose on their own
okay great so let me stop here there's a
lot of other examples that we can come
up with
i have a few here so one is sort of
limited self-control that's one of my
favorite pictures about
a gym attendance where you say well uh
you know they seem to be people have
preferences for going to the gym
um but then you know there's an
escalator um and people like you know
not working out so much so in some sense
uh something is is perhaps um a miss
here when you look at sort of
i mean this is one of my favorite things
to do is like in or not just not quite
as
it's a it's a fun thing to do i mean one
of my favorite things um
uh um uh uh when you sort of google um
uh terms and this is um calories or
weight watchers or the like
where you say well what is people's
interest in googling those kinds of
terms
over the course of a year and as you can
imagine what you see are these spikes
are essentially
january 1st people start sort of like
googling calories they like start
googling weight watchers and so on and
so forth
and now of course you can sort of think
about some models that sort of can
rationalize
in some sense in saying like well
january is just a good way to start a
a diet and so on but you know really the
the right thing to do is sort of people
and january 1st they have all the best
of it
intentions to lose weight uh uh eat
healthier um
exercise more and so on and so forth and
then you know um
uh the year starts the semester um
happens and so on and so forth
and the good attention sort of like um a
fade away which is essentially as
um limited self-control um
there's some interesting things about
demand for information especially when
it comes to
health you know every time i ask this
um and i've taught this class a few
years
so far every time i ask this i should
have realized how old i am who knows dr
house
oh not bad so can anybody explain to me
13 and dr house and what is sort of
their deal and what does this have to do
with demand for information
so who's 13 or what is her health issues
she's got like i think yes she has
huntington's yes right so
[Music]
right so she has a disease which is
called huntington's disease which we'll
also
talk about more in the class which
essentially is a brain disease
where over time your brain more or less
degenerates and that's a
it's a really a bad condition and uh
where like at age 40 50 that manifests
and
it's a very serious condition it's a
genetic disease in the
in the sense that like if your parents
have that disease the chance of you
having it is way way higher than
in the general population uh there's a
test for it but there's no cure
so now um the dilemma and the show then
comes where
uh she essentially is thinking about
getting tested
and dr house who's in some ways very
rational and others not so much
essentially encourages her to test or
get that test
and any rational model would say well
you should really get that
or any sort of neoclassical model would
say you should get that test why why
should you get the test
why is that helpful and what's that
health information helpful for
right exactly you would say information
is good why is information good because
there's lots of important choices that
you might make
that depend on that information you
might think about like how much money
you want to save you think about like
your choices
about taking vacation about
career choices about partner choices
about having children
all sorts of issues about health
behaviors you might sort of take better
care of yourself
there's all sorts of really important
decision that might hinge on the fact
like
your life will be dramatically different
whether you have huntington's disease
or not now 13 does not want to i think
she actually does the test and then
doesn't want to see the result
and why is that yes
and so that's one view to view that i
think you know in some things as i said
you may could make other decisions like
economic choices you could save more you
could see the doctor more you could
go more on vacations or whatever do fun
things in life but you could say well
maybe that's not that important but the
neoclassical or the the classical
economics model
would still argue that you should get
that information it wouldn't hurt you
you wouldn't want to refuse it
so why is she but why is she refusing it
yes i think maybe she doesn't want to
leave the rest of her life
exactly so she essentially derives
utility from
information if you want from her beliefs
she likes to sort of pretend to herself
that she's healthy or like the chance of
her being healthy is very high
now under some assumptions you might
want to not get tested and sort of see
the results
of that test because once you have the
test it's very hard to pretend
if it's positive it's very hard to
pretend to yourself uh
uh uh that you're healthy because
there's a hard test saying that
um before the test you can still sort of
think like try to forget about it and
try to sort of live a happy life
sort of until the symptoms set in
but that's a clear violation of the
classical model of the assumptions that
i was showing you
above
the next part is uh default effects so
what i'm showing here here is the
fraction of organ
donors by country and type of default
there's uh
two types of defaults um often for organ
donations
this is from a few years ago but i think
overall things have not changed that
much um there's opt-in versus
opt-out so in the countries on the left
essentially you have an opt-in policy in
a sense like if you don't do anything
you're not an organ donor
so you have to like actively say in some
form or some form of like declaration
that you want to be
an organ donor on the right there's like
opt
out policies which means essentially if
you don't do anything you'll be
automatically
registered or viewed as an organ donor
you can opt
out but only um uh only if you do so
you'll actually be opted out otherwise
if there's an accident in the lake
you'll be viewed as an organ donor
now what's weird about this graph or why
is this sort of uh
potentially a violation of the
neoclassical or the typical economics
assumptions
yes the
people have the same preference of
whether they want to opt-in or opt-out
that everyone should have this would be
the same proportion across
but the difference is that um the effort
required to make that change or the
difference the lack of indifference
causes there to be the imbalance between
the opt-out and the opt-in
right exactly so um some people on uh
you know
don't want to get in trouble but some
people argue germany and austria is
actually not that different so i'm
german so you know some austrians might
disagree but you would say you know
overall germans and austrians are not
that different overall and you think you
know their preferences in particular
they might be different but their
preferences for organ donations
are probably pretty similar across those
two countries which is a reasonable
assumption
second lots of people care a lot about
what happens to them after they die
right so they for whatever reasons
religious or others they might actually
care a lot about at the end of the day
um uh what happens to their body and so
on and that's obviously their choice
um to make now if you assume those two
things
then it's very hard to reconcile this
this picture
because essentially um the opt in and
out out is a very small change to make
it's very um simple and easy to do you
just have to like fill out some form
maybe it takes you an hour maybe two you
have to maybe go to some office or the
like
but if you really care you could easily
do it
yet you see huge differences in outcome
based on this very simple
um small change which it's very hard to
model a right on a model that sort of
rationalizes this behavior
so somehow the default sort of the way
in which the decision is presented
seems to really affect people's behavior
in a fundamental
way
okay next one is glow caps this is like
a
help for people to take their medication
in particular for the elderly
which essentially is a reminder um uh
for people you can sort of program this
in certain ways
like every day or every few hours um a
glow cap
starts either sort of making sounds or
like starts blinking and the like
and gets you to take your medication and
it's a very sort of simple proof of
concept that you know reminders are
important and can save people's lives
and people have done studies on that and
so on
but essentially it's a very simple proof
of concept that memory is limited
right if your memory was perfect if you
could remember everything if you sort of
had all sorts of if you're a perfect
information processor
you would not forget about your
medication especially if it's important
especially if it's medication
uh that potentially saves your lives yet
you know we see that people's demand
people's uh uh medication usage um
is uh strongly affected by sort of types
of policies or products
um that can help people uh remember so
that's essentially a rejection of um
perfect memory
um next one is charity so if you think
about you know um
people in all sorts of ways seem to care
about others in the sense of like just
giving
uh money uh here's one charity that's
called gift directly which is
a very nice charity in a sense that like
what it does essentially is
a very simple way of helping the poor by
just directly transferring money
to poorer countries so on the right you
see an actual recipient from
give directly that person has a phone
they're sort of a mobile
phone based uh transfers where
essentially you can send money to people
with mobile phones
so if you decided now to give hundred
dollars um
to that person it could be that person
or a similar person
uh 95 of those or 90 of those dollars
would then in fact arrive at the phone
a cell phone of that person now um
why are people doing this presumably
because they care about others one way
or the other
um it could be either that you know in
some sense that's part of the utility
function just donating money to others
makes you happier and that's essentially
a way in which you improve your
well-being you just have
others well-being in your utility
function or it could be things like what
we said previously it could be like you
sort of think it's like appropriate
thing to do maybe other people's do it's
like an important thing to do maybe you
could tell your friends about it and so
on and so forth
but one way the other people give lots
of money to charity which in some sense
says one way or the other you must care
about others
overall so others are in your utility
function
so now attention um if you've seen this
before um uh
don't tell your friends about it here's
a simple attention test that i want you
to
do what's interesting about this is in
some ways like
um you know you might have seen this
before some of them may have she's seen
the gorilla before
uh who didn't see the gorilla it's okay
i didn't see it either but something
some people have seen it before that
there's a bunch of experiments that
people have done that essentially show
that you know often
a large fraction of people don't see
this gorilla
and there's various ways in which people
do other types of experiments
there's types of experiments where
essentially people
they go to like some bank teller the
bank teller says i'm going to go away
and then comes back and then there's a
different person who comes back and
people don't notice
there's various versions of that and so
what's interesting about this in some
sense is
so a it proves in some ways that
attention is limited
you just focus your attention on some
things and not others
and you might miss important things now
that's okay in some ways there's sort of
a version of that that says well
it might be sort of like rational
inattention in some sense you focus on
the important things in life and you
might miss some things and that's okay
in some sense
i ask you or the video asks you to count
the number of
passes so in some sense the gorilla is
irrelevant and that's true in this case
but in many other cases people might
sort of not rationally pay attention
they might sort of miss
some really important things in their
lives in part because you know they're
distracted and part because they don't
want to
pay attention and so on um and sort of
some of the strand of behavioral
economics which we'll talk about is sort
of like
when people do not pay attention and
then make mistakes
because of that
okay so i could go on and on with lots
of different examples but
the bottom line here is that most
researchers in psychology economics
believe that the classical um model of
behavior to the homo economics is too
too extreme in various ways uh that that
person is too selfish
um too rational and too willful and um
you know in some ways we want to kind of
understand how relaxing some of these
assumptions
might make economic models more
realistic now in some sense
no economist would in fact argue that
the assumptions of the standard models
are exactly correct
the questions are are these deviations
important do they actually matter for
something important
in explaining people's behavior and you
know which of those assumptions for
deviations
uh actually matter and that's kind of
like the name of the the game here
um in fact when you look at sort of like
when you talk to cognitive
scientists uh psychologists etc um
they will tell you the world is full of
uh cognitive biases and uh you
might not be able to read this and
that's kind of the point there's like so
many different things in which we're
biased in some sense every choice that
we make or anything
we do there's lots of biases that
interfere with people's choices
and almost any choice you can think of
or any behavior they can think about
there will be a psychology or other
experiments showing that people do not
uh behave perfectly now
the key question then is which of those
assumptions are are important or which
of those assumptions
violations of assumptions should we
focus on and for that i want to step
back a little bit and say okay what is
actually a model
what are economic models are trying to
do and so what is a model a model
is a simplified representation of the
world um
and we we know in some sense that the
assumptions of the models are not true
they're sort of supposed to be
approximately true and
exactly uh false so when you think about
like used models of the earth
in some sense they're like flat
spherical ellipsoid and so on and so
forth
um models so good models do not accounts
for bumps and and grooves and so on
a perfect replica of the earth is not a
useful model to use
you kind of want to simplify and capture
the essence of what's what's um
important so now then what's a good
model well a good model and you can read
a bit about this in
and get back in lapses paper a good
model is supposed to be simple
it's supposed to be easy to work with
and tractable so in some sense you have
only like a few variables or a few
things that you uh
that matter it's conceptually insightful
in the sense that like
it it focuses on important things it
tells you about behavior that we really
care about and important ideas
it's generalizable in a sense like
ideally we are trying to look for some
behaviors
that are general in some sense so if i
can just explain you one simple choice
in one domain
and write a model about it but that
model doesn't apply for anything else
that's not a good model um to work with
the model is supposed to be falsifiable
in a sense like we can actually test
them
and that's kind of what we do in
experimental and behavioral economics we
try to test people's theories or
our theories and then sort of empirical
work and then sort of falsify
or reject models that are wrong
and we should be able to make good
predictions for people's
behavior now are the assumptions of the
standard models true for most people
the answer is no but the key insight
here is that
the key properties of good models is
simplicity so in some sense
assuming perfect rationality selfishness
and willpower is actually a simple thing
to do in some sense
the reason why economists have made
those assumptions to start with
is not necessarily because i thought
people are perfectly rational or or
that they're not these uh psychological
issues going on
the reason is actually simplicity it's
an easy thing to do you model how you
think people should behave
and how you behave perfectly and
making some of these models sort of
richer in their psychology is actually
complicated
and makes the models more complex and
harder to analyze
so that is just to say well then the
question is like can we find some
assumptions of economics can we make
them more realistic in a tractable way
in a sense can we find key things that
we change that
keep the models tractable while then
also explaining important things better
than we can before
right so it's not about just taking all
sorts of like psychological issues that
might be going on and say well
economic assumptions are wrong or models
of
economics are wrong or the assumptions
of those are wrong we know that these
assumptions are wrong
the question is can we make somewhat
simple assumptions or improvements of
those assumptions
based on insights from psychology and
other fields that help us improve those
models
and then make better uh predictions and
all of that in a tractable
way so now this is very important here
i'm a good behavioral economic economist
or
a good student in this class is also a
good economist
behavioral economics is not sort of
trying to replace standard economics
so i don't want you to go to my
colleagues and say you know 1401 1402
and so on this is all garbage frank is
telling you
um we do things differently in fact you
very much need to know those kinds of
things from like standard economics
to understand what the assumptions are
and how to best to deviate
from that and so as such then like key
principle
principles of mainstream economics
continue to apply
decision makers are still highly
sophisticated markets and incentives
matter
they're in fact play a key role in
shaping behavior
and markets allocate resources well most
of the time the question is can we sort
of focus on important deviations and try
to fix
those and then again like sort of
methodological principles still apply
you use observational experimental data
mathematical models are good and so on
and so forth
and ideally models would sort of nest
the special case stuff
perfect rationality or perfectly sort of
standard economic models i mean trying
to build in some parameters that
deviates from that and try to understand
can we make better
predictions and then so often prices are
actually the most important aspects of
choice
here's one experiment by ito at all that
try to essentially sort of change
people's um
energy usage and so on and they have
like two treatments one is uh
called moral suration which essentially
is telling people uh uh sort of
appealing to their morals in some ways
and the other one is essentially just
financial incentives straight up
changing the price of people's choices
and what you see in this experiment
essentially is
um uh there's a in red you have the
impact is all treatment effects over
time
comparing like a treatment group and a
control group and you see
and read the treatment effects of the
incentives and you see these are
relatively large and persists over time
and you see the treatment effects of the
moral suasion treatment which
happens to be you know reasonably large
to start with but essentially just goes
away
what we learned from that we were
learned from that prices matter and
maybe in this case
moral surveillance is just not that
important and that's perfectly fine
we're trying to identify sort of
situations or cases where some of the
underlying psychological issues are
important and we've learned from
an experiment that in some cases this
doesn't apply well so be it then we
should
focus on other cases where the
psychological issues are
are more important okay so then um
what sort of our broad approach to each
topic we're trying to sort of start with
intuitive empirical and uh experimental
examples how people behave in in some
situations
we're trying to think about their
motivations trying to see about how they
make choices and behaviors and how they
behave in certain situations and then
we're going to try to sort of model this
in a more precise way
and try to consider how the modeling of
that perhaps deviates from the
neoclassical
uh or sort of the classical model of
economics some other times you also just
start from the classical model of
economics look at the predictions and
say well
can we reject that or do we make certain
predictions that are just not true and
then say can we sort of improve those
types of
assumptions and then overall they're
trying to think about then you know how
these
hypotheses or deviations might be able
to explain how people behave and markets
and what choices they make
and how perhaps we can think about
policies that might affect the people's
well-being
their welfare or any other consequences
any questions so far
okay so um now i want to give you one
very
simple and some sense stylized example
of uh which would
demonstrate a little bit what sort of
like you know classical economic
uh standard uh economic assumptions are
and may
how sort of enriching a model with
psychological considerations
um might be more powerful so
um when you think about laptops in class
what are sort of
standard economic concept considerations
should you allow laptops should they be
laptops in class is that a good thing or
a bad thing or
what do we think about that
and now i'm asking for like standard
non-psychological issues just saying
like
he went to like a classical economist
and says should we allow laptops in
class
what would be considerations for that
yeah uh
yes so you know you could call that
a psychological or not but essentially
it could distract people essentially and
that's uh externalities tend to be sort
of like
uh very much like in classical economics
essentially if you smoke it affects
others similarly if a laptop it might
affect others
it's a little bit sort of in the middle
between psychological and economic
considerations because in some sense
uh you know if somebody next to you
would use a laptop
and i would just say well why don't you
just focus on class anyway you should be
able to just ignore that
but setting that aside that exactly
externalities are surely one
considerations that we have
what's the pro side why would we allow
laptops
what's good about laptops in class yeah
like it could just be efficient for
taking notes some people might need to
use them some people maybe are
dispensing
stuff like that so it's just good
exactly it's like a useful technology
to take notes and you might just be
better that it might be more comfortable
it's easier for it to do
maybe it's also saved some paper or
whatever
what else are laptops good for yeah i
mean
more choices just always better so if
each person has their laptop they can
choose what's better for them
yes exactly if you are so inclined and
want to watch football from yesterday
the replay and so on if you prefer that
and that's good for you
uh you know who should be stopping you
right and so
uh at some sense laptops are useful for
um
note-taking they're also useful for uh
non-class activities
and as you say each student should be
able to choose for themselves
um what's good and um uh that may be
involved like paying attention or or or
not
now what else sort of some psychological
conservations we had one of them which
is essentially distracting others which
essentially is the externality
um what else yeah
right exactly you might sort of uh have
all the best intentions of taking notes
of the what i said previously but then
you know
it gets a little dull and boring at
minutes when it's 40
and you might sort of be inclined to
sort of think about other uh stuff and
sort of start surfing in the internet or
the like or start chatting or whatever
that sort of essentially limited
self-control one way or the other
yeah yeah i think so i think even if you
don't fall into the limitation
you kind of have to spend energy
resisting that temptation and that might
kind of distract you
right so there's some cognitive
resources potentially from
from that that's a very nice observation
exactly that that also might be true
there's another part to that which is
people tend to overestimate how much
they can multitask and there's
like a large number of experiments that
say well i'm actually paying attention
i'm look you know i'm just sort of
reading some other stuff i'm chatting
with my friend
um and people actually think they pay
attention and they learn
trust me they do not so essentially
there's a large large literature on
people thinking that they can
multitask when in fact they cannot
there's a very human thing to do
you might think you know you can study
for an exam by watching tv
chances are you're not studying um very
well so that's essentially some form of
like um
um overconfidence um
right and then there's another part
which is sort of like uh
uh sort of some with different
psychological consideration which is
people tend to not like hard paternalism
as in like if you sort of like we talk
about this at the very end when we talk
about policy
people don't like certain hard rules
about like you're allowed to do this
where you don't allow to do x or y you
have to come to class or whatever
people tend to not like that um that's
more like another sort of consideration
you think about like what is the right
policy um
to do now what policy solutions could we
do what what laptop policies have you
seen or how do you think about them
maybe somebody else yes
i haven't seen it but let the people
with laptops sit in the back
yes you could have you could do that um
yeah
and sort of that's kind of like
minimizing the the externality
potentially
um it's not really helping with
self-control i guess
right because if particularly if you sit
in the back nobody sees what you're
doing
um and you might be so inclined to to do
all sorts of things
uh yes
right so that's sort of like hard
paternalism with some uh
exceptions potentially yeah
um i've seen like only devices that are
flat on the table
for note-taking yeah i've seen
track of class um so if they see you
doing something
not academic they can technically take
you forward
yeah that's what they're for no no
um anything else
i've seen classes where you're just
allowed to use your laptop because i
guess
right exactly that's sort of less affair
saying like you know what's best for you
in some sense since this is sort of like
a psychology income behavioral class
uh you know i i tend to
tend to disagree with some of those
assumptions but yes exactly that's less
affair
any other thoughts
uh okay so then uh here they are so
there's um less affair
there's educational intervention which
essentially just providing people
information
about um um laptops or what laptops do
for learning
uh there's some experiments i'll show
you in a second educational
interventions tend to actually not
work particularly well so essentially
just giving people information tends to
not change behavior
um often in the way we'd like to do that
you could tax laptop users
say it's costly to do that would be the
typical sort of like public economic
sort of solution
i think i'm not allowed to take money
from you guys so so i might not not do
that
you could ban laptops this is from um
that was a previous suggestion to say
except for students with medical need
you could make a non-laptop section the
default and let students opt out or
opt in depending on that and essentially
saying like
the default choice is one uh essentially
no laptops but you can opt into that
by emailing the a ta and then use it in
a certain section uh
we'll talk about in the problems in a
little bit why that might be a good idea
you could also set up an active choice
between the laptop and the no laptop
sections so here's the educational
interventions the the evidence and
there's very clear evidence from various
settings that shows that laptops in
class are not good for learning
on average there's a very nice article
by susan
donarski in the new york times he'll put
this this online as well that you can
read
but essentially one of these studies is
a randomized control trial that um
mit a grad student a former mit grad
student had done
in an intro econ class this is carter
adal and essentially what they find is
that allowing computers in class reduced
test scores by 0.18 standard deviations
that's quite a large
number that's essentially saying they
didn't randomize across classes like
at the classroom level whether they
allowed laptops in class or not
interestingly they found negative
effects both of like unconstrained
laptops like
any laptop use but also the flat tablet
solutions so even the flat tablet
solution was worse than sort of the note
taking
which pen and paper um you know and
there's a bunch of evidence that sort of
shows that
so in this class what we're going to
have is sort of a version of opt-in
policy which is there's going to be a
laptop
section starting next class which is
going to be on the front and one side of
the class
the reason being we're trying to sort of
minimize externalities
uh it's in the front not in the back um
the reason being that
if you're in the very back then there's
no supervision i'll i guess ask some uh
tas to sit sort of like in the back if
there's too much uh
other activities going on maybe there
won't be a laptop section um
anymore anyway there will be sort of
conservations about that and the problem
said
but the point of all of that is to say
if you just had the standard economic
considerations you would make certain
policies um
on very sort of simple considerations by
missing important facts
and that might be sort of the
psychological externality might be the
self-control problems
the overestimation of people's ability
to multitask and so on and so forth
and all of those things might sort of
like interfere with people's optimal
choices
and that that makes certain more
paternalistic policies uh
potentially more promising but again
in the problem said you'll you'll think
about some of these um uh solutions
any questions on the laptops yes i might
be thinking of a different study but it
is the same one it i thought that in
their other classes they
previously were not like allowed to use
laptops so
it might be that they had not optimized
themselves for
laptop usage during class that's
interesting uh
so i think there are several studies
that show that um i don't know the
details on
that uh but if you can send that to me
i'm happy to
to just look at that and reconsider i
think my my view overall is that sort of
the the existing evidence essentially
shows laptops
are bad since i'm interested in your uh
learning um um and that's what i go with
but i'm happy to be um to be educated
um i'll try and put the slides online
um i was the night before in case you
want to print them out or look at them
or whatever during class
i'm um you're welcome um to do that
okay so then let me tell you very
briefly about like um
uh different topics of the class and
what we're gonna
cover so first we're gonna have an
introduction uh and overview
today's introduction lecture the
overview um will be on wednesday we'll
show a cover kind of like
providing an overview what the different
topics are and how to think about them
and what evidence do we actually have
so i was kind of like a little bit hand
wavy in a sense of like showing you lots
of like
flashy pictures of people misbehaving
but in fact um you know i'm going to
show you some more sort of rigorous
evidence that we have that in fact
uh some of the assumptions of the um
classical
model are violated and sort of like how
we think about them and how we might
sort of incorporate them into economics
so that's going to be an overview on
wednesday
then we're going to talk a lot about
preferences you can think about
essentially
when people make choices there's a
utility function and sort of
one set of behavioral economics issues
or
changes to the utility function this
might be time preferences and people's
self-control
which we already discussed it might be
risk preferences how people think about
risk or they think about gains and
losses and how their preferences are
reference dependent
this is what um a student was saying
earlier about like
how you evaluate something might it
depend a lot on your expectation of that
outcome
as opposed to just the outcome itself
uh let me talk quite a bit about social
preferences this is sort of like how
much we
uh uh how much we weigh others um
utility uh in our youtube our utility
function or their consumption and our
utility function
uh we'll do some experiments in class um
on that which which
should be a lot of fun and then discuss
various issues about a how much people
care about others and how they're
affected by others behavior and social
influences so that's kind of like the
first half of the class broadly about
like
changes in people's then preferences
going to talk more about beliefs
broadly speaking and sort of people's
how people
view information in the world you talk a
little about emotions what's called
projection and attribution bias
these are issues about for example when
people are hungry
or tired they might make quite different
choices
um and and so that might affect their
preferences
but it might also affect their their
beliefs in some sense if you think about
how you're going to behave if you're
hungry right now it's very hard for you
to believe or
think about like that you're not might
not be hungry in the future this is sort
of the classical example of
shopping on an empty stomach um there's
lots of different applications of that
it's like people buy convertibles when
it's sunny um and then return them when
it rains
but there's also much more serious
issues in particular things like
depression for example when people are
depressed it's very hard for them to
think about
how it might feel when they're not
depressed anymore in the future
so we'll talk about sort of production
and attribution bytes which is kind of
these biases and how to think about
people's
states of the world we talk about
limited attention that people sort of
don't pay attention to certain things in
the world and sort of how that might
affect people's behavior
how we might sort of exploit that
potentially for taxing them or how we
might sort of direct their attention to
certain things and might improve their
behavior
similarly then we talk about beliefs and
learning this is kind of like
how what information do they have
available a you know how they
update uh their beliefs when they get
information and are they able to process
information well
b is the demand for information do
people get utility from beliefs this is
what i was talking about like
health behaviors other health
information where people might have
motivated beliefs in the sense that like
they like to
believe certain things uh um
when in fact they're not true in part
because it makes them happy or in part
because they want to be right about
something
or their party or whatever uh you'll
talk a little about mental accounting
which is like
people tend to sort of narrowly bracket
their choices they might sort of have
certain accounts in their behavior and
decide sort of separately
as opposed to aggregating their behavior
as a whole
and that sort of issue that's less
research but quite interesting overall
then we're going to move towards sort of
more radical deviations if you want from
the standard model which is
things like malleability and
inaccessibility of preferences which is
to say
people might not actually know what they
want they might not even understand what
their preferences are
or their preferences are easily
manipulable i can sort of like make you
choose a or b
or b or a versus b or b versus a
depending on what kind of situation i
put you in
and you might not even notice that i'm
doing that um and in fact
and that makes things a lot trickier
because then in some sense it's much
harder to sort of say
should the government or any sort of
other policymaker choose a or b
if we don't even know what people's
preferences are people don't even know
what their own preferences are
we're going to talk about happiness and
mental health this kind of broadly
speaking what makes people happy and can
we think about that in particular sort
of like financial choices and others
i'll tell you a little bit about some of
the work on mental health that i have
been
doing thinking about kind of like how
mental health might affect economic
behaviors and choices and in part how
people's demand for mental health
interventions
might be shaped by influences of others
uh we're going to talk about gender and
racial discrimination um which sometimes
there's sort of
classical and neoclassical models of
discrimination
when we in particular think about sort
of issues of discriminations that are
sort of not
uh rational in the sense of like uh
think about like unfair in some sense um
discrimination
um finally going to talk about sort of
policy and paternalism
uh one broad issue is about and this
goes back to malleability and
inaccessibility of of preferences which
is
essentially ways in which choices can be
affected through frames defaults and
nudges assumptions that say
i can manipulate your choice
architecture in certain ways that make
you choose certain things
uh you know i might sort of send you
letters to do your taxes i can sort of
like
frame certain or set certain defaults
for
organ donations or for uh savings
choices and the like
and that might have profound effects on
people's behavior
uh once we go through that in the sense
of like showing you some evidence that
people
it's possible to do that we're going to
talk a little bit about policy and
paternalism in a sense of like say
okay now if i know i can change your
behavior in certain ways
what kinds of policies should we do and
should we in fact do that
or you know should we tax people should
we set certain frames and defaults
and you know i'll be potentially making
some people worse off while making some
people better off by doing these kinds
of
policies there's often also some ethical
issues
associated with that and then finally i
talk about poverty this is sort of
mostly the research
that i do and thinking about sort of
poverty issues through the lens of of
psychology again i'll tell you a little
bit about the the work i do myself
um partially to talk a little bit about
so how
financial constraints are just thinking
about money affects people's behavior
and then second how other issues related
to poverty might
shape people's choices
decision making and their sort of labor
market outcomes earnings and so on
and whether it's potentially something
that you might want to call a
psychological or behavioral
poverty trap any questions on these
topics
okay so then readings for next time this
is wednesday please read
um there's a paper on the course website
um by matthew raven who is one of sort
of like the
uh all-stars in behavioral economics
uh 20 years ago he already wrote a very
useful perspective on psychology and
economics that sort of discusses a lot
of the issues of
behavioral economics how to think about
that um again read sections one and two
we're not going to sort of test you
specifically on like very specific
things but you should sort of be able to
sort of
uh remember at least roughly what's
what's in that paper